whoa didn't he like go
he did let go
um I think he did I think he did he let
go that allows the move Bishop C5 no but
it's touch it's it it's not it's touch
move clearly that is not touch release
but did he let it go yes
absolutely Jen you said you asked what
kind of form buried this car off he's in
the big test
an extremely well played game between
Gary Kasparov and Hikaru Nakamura we
reached this grip prior to playing this
move he had actually put the Knight on
B4 and did he release the did he release
it let's take a look indeed let's take a
look and note that and here we go right
but he did not he really he released it
without him yeah
even and that rewind here we go once
again
he almost hit the clock
hikaru's face right there
saying man if he's gonna play a move
like night before I am going to win this
match even if I don't win this game
okay and Gary
and players are back at the board and of
course Knight B4 would have been a
disastrous blunder instead Malcolm or
just got a small in-game Edge and
um Gary defended well and scored the
draw
[Music]